hey good afternoon guys
traffic uh still moving very slow people
have been waiting several hours i'll
give you a live look here at the 15. we
are in jean right now you can see
this line of traffic earlier today we
left las vegas
at around noon and it took us an hour
and a half just to get here to jean now
it took people several
hours to get to state line las vegas was
said to be a top destination for the
holiday weekend
traffic started to build up early this
morning and throughout the day people
were
sitting in bumper to bumper traffic at
one point there was
a 26-mile backup according to rcc now
some were stopping in the middle of the
road to stretch while others were
waiting it out in jean or prim
now people say they expected the traffic
for the holiday but they did not expect
it to take three hours to travel
30 or so miles i just want to go home
that's the thing uh it's hard
there's not there's i mean we have to go
to south
so-cal and it's a long drive it's going
to be it's a hot day
vegas is definitely back vegas is back
you see all this traffic
this is ridiculous
nevada highway patrol was out in full
force today earlier today they uh sent
out a tweet
that they already were pulling over
people for driving impaired and others
who were trying to drive on the shoulder
now back out here live we're taking
another look at people trying to exit
the 15 south here at gene people again
just waiting a long time just to get to
this gas station which has
around 90 or so pumps people waiting a
half an hour or so just to get a drink
inside so people just trying to take a
break here
but people are just going to be waiting
even longer to get to pram and there's
even a little bit of traffic
coming northbound on the 15 as well but
people say
unfortunately they're just going to have
to wait to sell out reporting live
near jean joe mullen 8 news now